Thank you to skillshare for sponsoring
this video.
The clash of giant men and monsters is
eight powerful image that has a beard in
many religion,
mythology and forth till throughout the
ancient world,
and it's a concept that in our secular,
modern world continues to live on in the
somewhat different form.
Guillermo del Toro specific written is
one of those manifestations and although
at very consciously embraces the
silliness of the genre,
it nonetheless managers do transcend the
cliche by hinting edits,
very deep symbolic patterns of society
and the individual of how a world or a
center can come both to be destroyed and
reborn on the edge or the rim of the
world.
Yeah.
To begin with,
the story gives us a mythological
version of the modern world.
Deep in the Pacific Ocean appears a riff
to a dark dimension of giant monsters.
We rubbed out of the water as out of
primordial chaos.
The fact that the rift manifests in the
Pacific Ocean is not arbitrary because
according to how we have mapped in
organize the world,
even though the world is a globe,
it is nonetheless there in the Pacific
Ocean that the rim of the world is
located where East becomes west,
where time jumps from one day to
another.
Her rift in spaced imaged as the gate of
Haiti's out of which chaos and death
erupt,
and so following the analogy,
the edge,
the rim of the world in terms of space
is also where appears the possible end
of the world as cataclysmic destruction
of all civilization.
The possibility of the end appears in
the form of the Kaijene we're emerging
out of the water are monsters in the
fullest sense of that word depicted here
as undefinable hybrid creatures mixtures
of humanized forms and diverse animal
characteristics.
They remind us of the universal sea
monster that has appeared all over the
world in the form of the Leviathan,
the Crackin,
trib dis are Cilla.
All of these creatures come together as
a representation of chaos and the
destructive forces of nature.
As rally points out,
there are things you can fight,
acts of God.
You see a hurricane coming,
you have to get out of the way for when
you're in a yeager,
suddenly you can fight the art game.
You can win.
However,
the eruption of chaos,
which happens on the edge is not just
accidental,
but simultaneously appears as an
invasion of a foreign race of aliens
because if what lies outside the wall of
the city is the danger of the natural
world,
it is also the unknown stranger as
possible invader.
And so unlike other movie monsters such
as Godzilla who represents rod
destruction,
the Kyde,
you linked several aspects of the rim
and the periphery together linking
closer to cosmic symbolism,
the somewhat humanoid forms of these
monsters.
The fact that they often walk on two
legs also links the more general sea
monster to the image of the clash of
titans or the giants which appear in
almost all cultures as preceding the
civilized world.
Having had to be defeated in a war or
destroyed in a flood in order to make
way for a current age and just like the
ancient ages of giants founding myth,
we're told the dinosaurs were Kaijene as
well,
linking the edge of the world where
chaos erupts with an ancient forgotten
time populated by monster
to answer this unending emergence of
chaos from the rim.
Humanity joins hands to bring forth an
army of giant human controlled robots or
yeager's.
But what makes it so intuitively right
that Earth's line of defense should come
in the form of a giant man.
The strange satisfaction of the Mecca
robot is that it is a man that the skill
of society at giant weapon to defend the
world and vision as the physical
embodiment of the spirit,
which represents a communion.
It's the image of the Saint Michael
figure who brings order food defeating
to gray dragon of chaos by slashing him
with his sword.
It's division of the giant man
representing the community and if the
Commonwealth represented and Thomas
Hobbes own version of the Leviathan.
This premise of the Jaeger as the
embodiment of communion appears.
First of all,
in the name of the yeager leader
Marshall Pentecost for pentecost as to
possibility of finding unity among
diversity when the Holy Spirit made it
possible for people with all languages
to understand each other and so to the
Jaeger program has shown as diverse
peoples and cultures joining together to
fight a common enemy or more succinctly.
The very efficiency of the yeager.
Robots depends on two or more people
coming together into perfect unity,
communing or drifting together with all
their memories,
their faults,
and with all their willpower.
Like any society or people who share a
common identity like the two sides of a
brain,
like the opposites which characterize
the human person,
creativity and discipline,
justice and mercy,
freedom and submission to societal
norms.
It's not obvious.
It is Mr [inaudible].
He defensive.
Unity can only be possible when
opposites come together into focus and
common purpose,
but the Jaeger is not only an image of
communion,
but an image of the edge itself,
an extension of technology as the
expansion of human capacity.
Clothing is the most primordial image of
technology.
The most immediate gloving is protection
of weakness and increase in the power to
master to hostilities of the outside,
so like a giant night of cosmic
proportions,
the yeager's,
both an armor and a weapon which can
move into the periphery to meet the
challenge which appears on the edge
in their status and in the expression of
the characters.
The Jager team itself has depicted as
representatives of the margin.
They are the exception.
They are a rag tag group of drift
compatible couples and they are pushed
out of the center and discarded when in
their overconfidence things start to go
downhill and a society now ops to hide
from chaos behind a giant sea wall
instead.
Visually the move towards the edge is
represented as a descent.
This image is repeated over and over.
The head of the Jager with its human
agents descend unto the body than the
Jager is dropped into the waters and
ultimately the jager moves to the bottom
of the ocean floor in order to descend
even into the pit,
into the chaos of the underworld where
the monsters come from
and where to yeager's were at first part
of the military hierarchy of the center.
They now adopt an identity more closely
aligned with the hybrid heroes at the
frontier and they haven't been sort of
the graded into the resistance and I
have them talk in the language of a
western Marshall Ryder outpost,
Jaeger jokey.
You'll see when they moved,
they sound like cowboys instead of
dealing with governments,
they are now forced to do business with
those that dwell in the shadows in
between worlds.
This in between.
This is also noticeable in the
resemblance of the yeager and decayed
you firstly in their name,
which are permutations of each other,
but also in their mirrored appearance as
giant extensions of their societies
engineered by either side to fight
monsters.
We created monsters of our own,
the yeager's,
our emissaries and guardians of order.
On the one hand,
but as giant weapons of nuclear
proportions.
They also like the hive mind control
guide.
You embodied it potential for mass
destruction and here in lies both the
necessity and the danger of the descend
in order to effectively overcome the
unending destruction caused by the riff.
The yeager crews are forced to both
voluntarily and involuntarily be touched
by chaos.
Riley loses his brother and this left
with a print of the cage he was making
on his body,
causing him to resigned to a red or
meaningless life behind the wall.
His partner,
Mako,
on the other hand,
is touched by the chaos of the Chi Jew
and a more mental way,
which takes the form of a severe
childhood trauma,
which has controlled her life in a quest
for vengeance that almost leads or to
point a gun at her own kind.
Decreased scientist.
Newton,
on the other hand,
Holt's an unhealthy desire to be
connected with the guide you,
which consequently leads into learn the
secret of their origin,
but it paradoxically also gives them the
information they need to figure out the
intentions of the Jaegers as well as his
own present location.
It's
fighting chaos on the edge in this
dissent in which we can both obtain the
power and the knowledge to emerge
victorious,
but in which there's also the danger of
becoming consumed by it perishing or
even reemerging as the very same thing
we had wanted to overcome.
Okay.
In the end,
the men and women of the Jaeger program
have to consciously find a balance on
this slippery slope in between order and
chaos,
and it's not only in the balance that's
found in this relationship or this
harmony of opposites,
but it's the individual as the place
where unity and resolution finder most
immediate form.
All of these characters have to reassess
their opinions and their compulsions in
order to to get our take up the sword.
One last time
in this final clash,
they learned that it is not only an
opposition,
that the guide you are to be defeated.
It's by merging with them in a strange
manner that unlocks the gate for a
yeager to make it's final descend into
the underworld.
This descend into the underworld can be
seen as the embracing of chaos without
being defeated by Riley writing to guide
you in to the rift.
This like Gandalf riding the Balrog
through the Ebis,
and ultimately it is an image of Christ,
descendants who Haiti's and ultimate
resurrection,
his trampling down death by death.
It's this voluntary acceptance of the
existence of chaos,
both without and within and coming
together in communion.
Despite that,
that the last act of courage and
sacrifice culminates into a single act
of the human person in a moment of
solitude,
destroying the power of the underworld
and finally closing to rift the return
to the surface as dare for shown as a
rebirth,
as the emergence of a new world free
from the madness of destruction,
but also the rebirth into a world where
the two opposites of Riley and Mako find
themselves united floating on an island
in the vast ocean.
As the final image of a new beginning.
This video was brought to you by
skillshare.
Skillshare has over 17,000 online
classes for you to learn a new skill,
right?
Or you're looking to learn how to write
consistently or how to get good at
making logos.
Skillshare has a wide range of options.
If you're interested in making video
essays for instance,
but you're scared off by adobe's editing
software,
try out to premiere pro course for
beginners or if you want to add more
flare to your work,
which is something that we've been
trying to do in our own videos.
Check out Evan Abrahams after effects
glass.
He will run.
You write for the basics,
which will make your life that much
easier.
The classes are made by experts in the
field.
They're detailed and there are more
organized and your run of the mill
youtube tutorial,
and we have a premium membership.
Starting from around $10 a month.
You can get unlimited access to
learning.
You can sign up with the link provided
below.
Lastly,
if you like our content,
you can also support us on patron and
paypal.
We've recently lost a number of patrons
because patron briefly up to Texas for
users.
Uh,
they've changed it backs in,
so it'd be pretty cool if you can help
us out and get us back up to speed with
just a dollar a video.
Anyways,
guys,
thanks for watching.
See you in the next one.